well hey y'all how you doing everybody
doing all right thank you so much for
coming to my talk
leadership guide for the reluctant
leader and I'm so excited to be here I'm
just really grateful to have another
opportunity to speak at a in DC
conference and I've had a terrific time
so far I hope you've had a great time
with some of the sessions that you've
been to and are learning and soaking up
all kinds of good content and
information at my previous company we
had this thing about punching bears it's
all about doing hard things and
generally being awesome and it was part
of our mantra he would say get out there
and punch some bears today in reality
punching bears is probably not such a
great idea as it will only provoke the
bear to maul you to death maybe a bit
worse so this has nothing to do with the
talk I'm about to give I just thought
you'd like some free advice now some of
you like me are just so excited you've
been soaking up information here but
going through all the different sessions
and you can't wait to get back to your
work place and just unleash all of your
new knowledge onto your unsuspecting
coworkers right others of you may be
feeling a bit overwhelmed there's you
know you're probably thinking how in the
world am I going to learn all this new
stuff how am I going to convince my boss
to allow me to use any of this new
technology that I've learned about and
you know now I'm here to to give you
throw some more stuff at you so we could
talk about you know where I see
technology going in the next five years
or you know some new trends and so forth
but that would be about as
accurate as the weather forecast IOT is
a really hot topic we could talk about
how we should be connecting everything
in all our devices all everything in our
homes to the cloud and reaping all the
benefits of a fully connected you know
distributed system of data collected
from all of our peripherals or we could
talk about the latest JavaScript
frameworks that was created only
yesterday that's now the new standard
and you can just forget about everything
that you've known or figured out by this
point but what if I told you that
regardless of the technology that you
know regardless of the technology that
you use a regardless of the job title
that you have that you have amazing
potential to impact your workplace and
your family your community and beyond in
powerful and meaningful ways so let's
start off with a story allow me to
indulge in a story about myself maybe a
cautionary tale if you will when I first
got into my career I was doing a mix of
IT and programming and I absolutely
loved solving problems and fixing things
I couldn't believe that I actually got
paid to do the things that I got to do
yes really really awesome and I hope
some of you get the reference there on
yes but a funny thing happened I was
promoted to a management position and I
absolutely hated it all I wanted to do
was sort of write code and to you know
put screws together and write you know
mount servers and you know do whatever
and I'm an introvert believe it or not
leaving my desk to go and talk to other
people
and manage a team and try to get people
to do stuff it just wasn't even remotely
in my nature I resented the role and the
responsibilities and I did the bare
minimum to get by within 18 months I
took a straight programming job making
less money and this cycle being promoted
to management and despair and changing
jobs repeated itself several times and
my wife would ask me what do you have
against about against making more money
well it wasn't just about the money
right it's my ideal job consisted of
give me the most powerful computer give
me a virtual unlimited supply of
caffeine and stand back while I sling
some code can I get an amen
right you know what I'm talking about it
wasn't until many years later and
through some mentoring and some training
and not to mention maybe a little bit of
maturity I began to realize that my
attitude towards everything outside of
just cranking out code needed an
attitude adjustment and so I've had to
come to terms with being a leader and I
want to give you some things that I
think well that I've learned that it
maybe will help you along your journey
as well now you may think what I used to
think and that's leadership means is
only for management that you know and
for the longest time I didn't want to
have anything to do with being in
management but leadership is not just
for management it's not to say that
there aren't some aspects of if you're a
manager you need to have leadership
skills and have leadership abilities
but even if you're not in a management
role there are things that you can learn
to where you can be a leader and be a
person of influence and have respect for
people and a number of things that can
help you with your career and with your
relationships with other developers and
other other people in your organization
and you can have great influence on
folks so what I'm here to tell you is
that leadership is for all y'all and if
you've not you're not familiar with the
term all y'all it's it's it come I'm
from the US in case you didn't you
didn't notice there's you one singular
one person there's y'all which refers to
like two three four or five people and
then when you mean everybody you say all
y'all there are qualities and skills
being a leader that we all need to learn
a few years ago I was at my previous
company a group of us completed a
one-year leadership course in at the
scholar scarlet Leadership Institute in
Nashville Tennessee and our group was
named the emerging leaders but every
time I saw the the title emerging
leaders I thought it looked more like
our Maggard and so that's what I
secretly called our our group I called
us the armored guard leaders and every
six weeks or so we would get together an
offsite a training facility and we would
learn a core leadership skill we learned
about things like team dynamics
resolving conflict public speaking
communication lots and lots of things
and I highly highly recommend this type
of program or something similar to it if
you can find it if you want to grow
leaders and you know potential managers
and all those kinds of things
in your organization you've got to equip
your people to be able to fill those
kinds of roles because their skills and
things that you know a lot of us coming
from a development background we have no
desire at all to want to learn those
skills we want to focus on technology
and learning the new and shiny bits and
though and just interact with our
computers right so one of those to give
you an example one of those core
leadership skills that we learned about
is negotiation and we we role-played in
this particular training session we
broke up into groups of teams and we
learned in the form of like some legal
case documentation a summary of our side
of the story what we knew about the the
other side of the story maybe some
tactical information about how do we
would negotiate and each round of this
role-playing taught us specific skills
and tactics for negotiation we learned
things like the importance of doing
research so that you not only know all
the information you can about what
you're negotiating for but more about
who you're negotiating with the
importance of your Batna which is your
best alternative to a negotiated
agreement this helps you to know when
you when you should walk away from a
deal when the deal is no longer you know
as good as what you can get somewhere
else then you can walk away from that
deal and also the importance of things
like anchoring look usually the first
person who throws out a solution or a an
idea of what the negotiation ought to be
that the the whole conversation around
that negotiation is anchored from that
starting point and you have a lot of
advantage for the rest of the
negotiation if you're the one that can
be the first to offer a solution now at
the end of the day our instructor
cautioned us that the negotiation skills
that we
learned were extremely powerful and that
we should only use our new powers for
good and not for evil right so about a
month later I found myself in the market
for a new vehicle I did my research I
knew what I wanted I knew I understood
all the options that were available and
I knew what to expect from my adversary
and I knew that I could walk away from a
deal that wasn't as good as my Batna my
best alternative to a negotiated
agreement an opportunity presented
itself the day that I had to go to the
dentist a used truck that I was
interested in showed up on a at a
dealership and I thought well while I'm
out I will stop by on my way back home
and check out this truck once I got
there and I and I got out of my car I
don't even think up my first foot it hit
the ground one of their sharks that was
right on top of me what brings you in
today and you know cuz that's the way we
talk there and I said well I just
finished with a dentist appointment and
I stopped here because I'm interested in
morning your your trucks he said buddy
research shows that there's two things
people hate doing the most and that's
going to the dentist and buying a new
car you're doing both in the same day
you must be tough indeed I am
when we got to his office he made the
mistake of letting me make the first
strike and that helped to anchor the
deal in with a number that I was
confident based on my research that was
near the you know their bottom line and
I had lots more firepower in my from my
training at my disposal and after the
dust had settled I had the exact truck
that I wanted and I knew I could turn
right around and sell that truck for at
least 2000 dollars more than what I just
paid for it walking away knowing you get
a good deal that's a an incredible
feeling negotiation is a leadership
skill that you definitely need in your
life not just for the workplace but in
the case of the workplace being able to
negotiate on behalf of your team behalf
of your organization either internally
or externally that's a huge win for you
to have that kind of skill to make a
difference for your coworkers one of the
books our leadership group went through
was the ideal team player by Patrick
Lynch Oni highly recommend this book in
this book he talks about three virtues
that every leader or every great
employee must possess this book can not
only help you identify and hire the best
employees but like for me it got me
thinking about how I can you know what
were my deficiencies what how did I line
up with these three virtues and what
could I do to improve myself so that I
could be an ideal team player the first
and probably the most important virtue
is humility and I've got loads of that
humility is is having no ego and
characteristics are you know not have
not being really concerned about your
own status caring more about your
team then then you do yourself and eager
to share the credit
when the credit is you know with those
that you work with humility as described
in the book however is is a spectrum at
one end of the spectrum we've got the
opposite of humility we've got people
who are arrogant and self-centered and
there are politicians who create
division and resentment on throughout
your organization or your team and on
the other end of the spectrum you've got
someone who almost appears to be humble
but who can be just as damaging they
discredit their own talents and their
value to the team and the worst thing is
they won't point out problems when they
see them because they feel like their
opinion doesn't matter this is really
where I fell on the end of the spectrum
you know I I really felt like I I didn't
have that much to contribute and so I
didn't speak up when at times when I
should have spoken up one of my favorite
authors
CS Lewis had this to say about humility
the heart of being humble is unselfish
motivation for your team and your
customers and what when you truly want
the best outcome for your team and for
everyone around you you are acting with
humility
the second virtue is hungry
unfortunately is this is not referring
to food I would pass that with flying
colors now a hungry is about passion and
taking ownership of work again there's a
kind of a spectrum of behavior on one
end you have someone whose life is
dominated by their work and to the
detriment of everything and everyone
around them and we definitely don't want
to be that kind of driven person and on
the other end we have someone who has
has no motivation
no passion they're doing the bare
minimum to get by they probably have a
really limp handshake all right you
don't want those fishy kind of people
you don't want to be one of those fishy
kind of people so what we need is to
strike a balance of being both
passionate about the work that we do
that is that is manageable and
sustainable and then last is a virtue of
being smart this is not about
intelligence this is about common sense
regarding the people around you it's
about you may have heard the term
emotional intelligence or emotional IQ
this is characterized by things like
active listening being engaged and
asking good questions in your group
being sensitive of how your words and
how your actions affect other people and
having empathy for your co-workers and
your customers to sum up it's it's just
having respect for the people that you
work with and the people that you work
for now every important you know session
a presentation has to include a Venn
diagram right
it's just unwritten rule and so the
leadership this leadership presentation
isn't worth squat unless I give you a
Venn diagram and you can't stop me
so humility and passion empathy
sensitivity respect for people all these
are choices that you can make things
that you can develop in your own life
and by doing so you not only become an
indispensable employee you become a
leader you become someone that other
people will look to and aspire to and
want to be more like you become a leader
did you know that different people have
different personalities
yeah
people have different behaviors they
have different ways of looking at the
world and they the way they process
information the way they make decisions
and how they respond to conflict our
industry attracts people list let's say
sub-optimal people skills we can be
productive and get quite far in our
careers just on our technical skills
alone most of us including myself and
especially in the past are far more
comfortable you know communicating with
our computer than dealing with the
irrational emotional waters of dealing
with people around us right so there are
many behavior and personality
assessments that are available that can
help you to get insight into how you can
insight into yourself and to into other
personalities other people my favorite
so far that I've come across is disk
disk stands for a bunch of words I don't
know I don't remember what they are but
it's a really awesome program just trust
me but what this does by going through
an assessment like this is that these
personality traits can provide insight
into behaviors and you know being able
to understand some people are action
oriented some people are are people
focused some people are reserved some
are you know focused around tasks now
there's no you know this is not science
this is not you know 100 cent guarantee
are accurate but something like this can
help you to understand your team how
each person prefers to receive
information how to how they process
information how they prefer to
communicate and receive that it's a
fantastic tool to help you understand
people that are different from yourself
and it's a fantastic tool to help you to
understand yourself for example some
people are really deep thinkers
and they don't like big surprises going
into a meeting and and and having a big
change announced and then immediately
expecting that person to give you
feedback and give you know get their
input that's not how they like to
operate they need time to process new
information and to formulate an opinion
and give their feedback now we need
people who are active and take charge
and are gung-ho and a can can react
immediately to situations but we also
need people who can think deeply about
problems and who can come up with you
know long-term solutions
well-thought-out solutions that are that
keep our gung-ho people grounded
understanding behavior and personalities
can go a long way to helping you
empathize with your coworkers and it
also gives you tools and you know
information and knowledge about how to
best communicate with other peoples of
other personalities so that you can be a
person of influence and a better
understanding of your own behavior can
help you to develop your own strategies
for your workplace just being able to
articulate to your manager hey this is
how I like to process information this
is how I'd like for you to communicate
with me that can make a huge difference
because maybe you weren't able to
articulate that before learning how
other people process information
communicate and how they respond to
conflict puts you in amazing position of
being a person of influence and
leadership what's your greatest weakness
don't you just love that question you'll
be in a job interview or performance
review and you know the questions coming
right and so you try to come up with
something clever like well you know my
greatest weakness is I work too hard
I can't help it I just have to get
things done on time it's it's a curse I
suppose well another powerful tool is
the strengths finder this book and
assessment is the result of years and
years of study and tens of thousands of
Reis surveys performed by Gallup each
one of each one of you has unique
talents and knowledge and skills and the
strengths finder is designed to help you
to a discover or identify your top 5
gifts help you and help you to maximize
those gifts according to them according
to this book in the and the research is
that focusing a lot of time on our
weaknesses and only will you know the
result is that you may have may be
mediocre at best you're not going to be
too excited about focusing on your
weaknesses when you're not able to use
your strengths at work chances are
you're gonna dread going to work you're
gonna have more negative interactions
with the people you work with
you're gonna achieve less that and you
want to and you have fewer creative
moments when we're able to focus on our
strengths we're in we're in an
environment where we're empowered to use
our top strengths you will be 100
percent more likely to be an actively
engaged and again this is another
awesome tool that can help you and your
team together to unlock and unleash a
lot of potential that you have and help
how your strengths complement each other
and how you can really target your work
to maximize those strengths let's talk
about multitasking our culture seems to
be fixated on multitasking we put it in
our job descriptions must be a good
multitasker
and we put it on our resumes best
multitasker ever and the truth is none
of us are as good at multitasking as we
think we are no matter how hard we try
to convince ourselves our industry talks
a lot about maximizing our you know and
utilize our utilization like every
employee needs to be a hundred percent
utilized we can't be wasting time but
let me ask you what's what's a highway
at 100 percent utilization yeah it's a
parking light and it's not just in my
opinion it's it's math it's true for
traffic it's true for fluid dynamics
it's true for electricity it's also true
for people kids love going to the zoo or
circus rather and big kids you know us
grown-ups we enjoy it too exciting to
see the lion tamer get in the cage with
the lion and convinced the lion not to
maul him to death that's cool now the
whip is awesome you know it's like
Indiana Jones kind of thing what what
but the whip does nothing for the lion
the whip is for the audience well what's
up with the chair now Lions have
incredible powers of focus that's what
helps them to be predators and you know
in the wild help them to survive when
you put the four legs of a chair in a
Lions face the lion can't decide which
of those four legs to focus on and so in
essence the lion becomes paralyzed with
indecision and we are as much the same
way when we have too many tasks on our
plate our brains become overloaded we
think we can switch from task to task
but our brain
in actuality don't stop thinking about
those things those problems it's it's
causing mental you know overload or
mental stress without us even realizing
it how many times have you gone to sleep
and woke up the next day and realized oh
well that's how to solve that problem
that's because our brains don't stop
thinking about it
it haunts us even as we sleep our
subconscious does not stop thinking
about the problems and the tasks that we
face the things that we do and that may
sound counterintuitive but do everything
in your power to limit your work to one
thing at a time you'll get more work
done and you'll do it faster if then
trying to juggle too many things at once
I submit to you that there are three
inevitable things in life there's death
taxes and there's power point
sooner or later it's going to happen
whether it's speaking to your team or to
your organization at a meet-up or maybe
even a conference you're gonna stand in
front of a group of people some of them
which are complete strangers and you're
gonna have to present some from
information in 2011 I finally got up the
courage to give my first talk at a
meet-up and I stink
I was terrible but a funny thing
happened I had people thank me for
sharing I had people tell me that I did
a good job I had people tell me to my
face that I did I did a good job
although I was certain that I was the
worst speaker in speaker history it took
a while for it to sink in but I learned
a really valuable lesson about the power
of community there are people out there
who are just really good at being human
people who will look past your mistakes
and they see the good and potential that
is in you and they encourage you to not
give up because when we do hard things
like share information and as a
presentation everybody benefits I hope
that every day I'm a little bit more
like one of those kinds of people who
are who are seeing value in others and
encouraging them to share what what
they've learned and their journeys
here's one of my favorite quotes
when I gave my first talk people didn't
remember how I fumbled around with some
global a sa X or a configuration issue
or something then the cause my demos to
fail they remembered me and they
remembered that even in some small way I
made a difference in their life or in
their career I helped them to learn
something in 2016 I had the privilege of
giving a keynote at a conference called
music city code in Nashville Tennessee
and I shared the same story about how I
got started and I had more than one
person come up to me afterwards and say
I remember I was there when you gave
your first talk and you're right you
were terrible now you might be thinking
I can understand being asked or
volunteered or voluntold to speak
why would I how would I voluntarily
choose to get up in front of people and
speak that's that's terrifying
and I totally get it it terrifies me
every time I get up to give a talk but
let me tell you having someone not only
understand your message but then to be
inspired to actually go and do that
thing that you're talking about to get
that kind of feedback from someone is is
one of the most rare and precious gifts
I have ever experienced to know that in
some way I affected someone that they
went on to try whatever it is that I was
talking about and usually the stories
come that come back are like yeah that
thing you you were talking about I went
and did this hold the other thing with
it it's like something I would have
never imagined that was possible it's
it's really really powerful public
speaking is an amazing skill that you
can learn that will set you apart an
open door
is an opportunity he's not going to go
on and on about the benefits of public
speaking
how it's launched me on all kinds of
trajectories of in my career and so
forth but it can launch you ahead as a
leader an influencer in your
organization and your community I can't
recommend it enough have you heard of
the Dilbert principle the most
ineffective workers are systematically
promoted to where they do the least
amount of damage management so early in
my career I worked under a manager who
exemplified the devil Dilbert principle
I really didn't like the man personally
or professionally and his incompetence
was legendary
he was notoriously bad mistakes were
named after him and yet he still
continued to rise in rank and
responsibilities and a lot of the work
that I was required to do under his
direction was of no value to anyone for
example I was asked to create a huge
binder of documentation of every store
procedure every method in the code that
we were writing no one was going to read
this ever meaningless and pointless work
is soul-crushing I tucked it out for
more than a year and I tried to find
ways to get out from under him but with
no hope and no relief in sight I found
another job and I said to myself I
resolved that life is too short to work
somewhere that stinks and I started
living by that philosophy and I offered
it as it as advice to others when I
heard them complaining about their
workplaces in technology we have this
incredible privilege that we were in
such high demand that we can we can
choose to go and get another
job if we want to that isn't the case in
every profession the problem is this
idea began to pollute my thinking in my
perspective when things started to go
sour I would say oh great here we go
again
time to find another job and years later
I was in a similar situation I wasn't
happy I started interviewing at other
companies and I had two attractive job
offers on the table and I was trying to
decide what I was going to do and that's
when my wife asked me a couple of
questions that stopped stopped me in my
tracks have you done everything that you
can do and if you left now would you
have any regrets fine
I declined the job offer I took
ownership of the situation and I
committed to doing everything in my
power to make my team successful in the
end
I left that job one year later but I
left not proud of the work that we had
accomplished it would had been one of
the most productive and prolific years
in my career and I had such such a bond
with the people that I worked with now
sure there can be toxic environments
career limiting situations amazing
opportunities that come along that
justify changing a job but for
everything else I've adopted a new
mindset I believe that life is too short
to let things stay the way they are
we've heard the phrase well that's not
my job well maybe it is your job maybe
taking ownership and responsibility is
the right thing to do and as it has
far-reaching effects I've learned that
it's okay to be honest with the people
that you work with to say you know what
can we do to fix this problem what to
talk to your management to have hard
conversations to say what can I do to
help it's always the right time to do
the right thing and in doing so in
stepping up and taking ownership and
ensuring that things get done the way
they ought to be done you become a
leader you become an influencer someone
that that people admire and look up to
now every now and again we have to say
goodbye to people that we work with
really good ones regardless of the
circumstances we let them know how much
they are appreciated and how we're going
to miss them and sometimes we throw a
party and tell stories about how you
know what kind of impact
they've they've made on our workplace
like hey remember that time when at
lunch when Julie made you laugh so hard
that milk shot out of your nose that was
awesome I'm really gonna miss you and
milk shooting out of your nose so one
day it struck me after some some good
folks had left the company that I was at
why can't we express our appreciation
all the time why do we have to wait
until someone's leaving to let them know
how awesome they are what why can't we
you know encourage them in that way
maybe if we had told them how much they
were appreciated and how much they were
valued they wouldn't be looking for
another job
so I started to run an experiment in
every Friday I would write a short
tribute to someone that I worked with
describing their awesome contribution to
the organization in this example Nakota
was our Customer Support Manager and as
someone described he did the work of
10,000 men he consistently went above
and beyond the call of duty to make our
customers happy and he is awesome now
the drawing that I would create is
wasn't that important it was just
something fun that I like to do and the
what I said about that person usually
wasn't all that earth-shattering it
wasn't you know all that fantastic the
real magic now get this the real magic
was what everyone else said throughout
the day story after story encouragement
high fives
it was absolutely beautiful and all I
did was just start the conversation this
experiment lasted for about a year and I
had so many people come to me and and
tell me how special it was to be honored
and celebrated by their peers in this
way
you see every one of us wants to know
that the things we do matter that our
work has value and that we have value
encouragement highlights a person's
strengths and is a positive
reinforcement of that behavior what is
it they want to go do now they want to
go do more of that stuff that that got
them recognized for being awesome they
want to keep that feeling of feeling of
making a difference in making an impact
if you know me you know I can't go very
long without talking about bacon
so I submit to you the highest award for
excellence when you encourage someone
feel free to use this image when you
encourage someone or a team of people
you they will continue to improve and
create amazing results and the
interesting thing is they go on to
inspire others to do those things and
those people go on to inspire even more
it's a chain reaction it's a vicious
cycle of encouragement that's what we
want now I grew up in a dysfunctional
family there wasn't a whole lot of
encouragement being shared so
encouragement for me just doesn't come
natural it's yet another skill that I've
had to learn and it's something that you
can learn to well here I'll give you an
example imagine you have a co-worker
named Mary and you go up to Mary and you
say Mary I want you to know how much I
appreciate all the database work that
you do for our team not only that but
you're always smiling and being cheerful
you are such an encouragement to me and
the people that work with you thank you
so much Paul
thank you for always being willing to
help I know I can count on you to help
me with whatever problem that I'm stuck
on it means a lot to me you are awesome
Marc thank you for uh always wearing
deodorant and coming to work fully
dressed keep it up buddy
see it's not that hard
don't wait if there's someone who you
know that that has impacted you in some
way either in the past or you know
recently let them know about it don't
wait until it's it's too late now don't
you wish you could just fast-forward to
the future where you could you got it
all together and you have it all
mastered and the reality is there's no
shortcut to success we get out of life
in proportion to the work we put into it
now I'm telling you all these things
about leadership not so that you can go
back to your workplace and start
pointing fingers it like haha you know
you're not doing it right
you know well if I was in charge things
would be different around here
no I'm telling you these things so that
you can take a hard look at yourself and
and and try to figure out what is it
that I can do to make an impact on the
people around me how can I be a more of
a person of influence how can I be
someone who is encouraging and having a
positive impact what changes can I make
to become the most valuable employee
this company has ever had or what
changes can I make to make my team the
most valuable team that this
organization has ever had if your
actions inspire others to dream more
learn more
more become more you are a leader so
said president muttonchops awesome
facial hair dude none of those things
inspire dream learned none of those
things require you to be a manager or to
have a fancy title I have one more story
I want to share with you Thanksgiving
1982 now I know you probably don't
celebrate Thanksgiving here but in the
u.s. Thanksgiving is our is one of our
you know honored celebrations of giving
thanks for the things that we have and
in my family my mother's family it was a
tradition for us to all get together at
my aunt's house about two hours away
from where we lived and this particular
Thanksgiving we all gotten in the car my
mom drove us to my aunt's house and
there it at my aunt and uncle's house my
cousin had one of these a trs-80 this
thing right now I don't know if I spent
the entire day at this computer at this
amazing device connected to a TV but it
certainly made an impression on my uncle
because some time after Thanksgiving we
got back in my mom's car and we drove
two hours and to my aunt's house and
there waiting for me was a cardboard box
with trs-80 a cassette drive a floppy
drive a dot matrix printer and this book
this one kind and very generous act
launched me on a journey of computers
and programming and a love for
technology even the illustrations in
this book surely inspired me because
it's something that written has
resonated with me for the rest of my
life if I ever write a book you can be
sure it's going to be full of silly
illustrations I continue to be inspired
by my aunt and uncle's example of not
only investing in their own family but
in countless lives of others and I can't
thank them enough for the impact that
they've had on my life in my career
that's led to this opportunity to be
able to stand up in front of a group of
fellow geeks like myself we'd probably
have a lot of the same stories that I
have and be able to have an impact on
other people you have an amazing
opportunity to impact your family and
your workplace in your community you
never know if some relatively small act
of kindness or a word of encouragement
or a small investment of your time could
be the catalyst that launches a young
person or a person of any age on a
lifelong journey of exploration and joy
and even their livelihood so this is my
challenge to you that regardless of the
technology that you know regardless of
your age or years of experience or lack
of experience regardless of the job
title you have you have amazing
potential to impact your workplace and
your family
your community and in and the entire
world in significant positive and
meaningful ways
go maximize your talents go take
ownership and responsibility go be
courageous and go inspire others go and
be awesome thank you
[Applause]
I'd be glad to take any questions that
you have if you would all I ask is that
you come up and ask me here and allow
everyone else to - to go on with the
rest of those sessions if you are
interested I have some of my silly
stickers up here come grab one there
feel free so enjoy the rest of your
conference